TONIGHT'S "INSIDE THE ISSUES"
SPECIAL.
THE SHOW HAS CLOSELY FOLLOWED
THE POSSIBILITY THERE COULD BE
UNKNOWN ENTITIES IN THE SKIES
ABOVE US.
I BELIEVE THAT.
COULD THEY BE CLOSER THAN
THAT?
RIGHT HERE?
A NEW "WALL STREET JOURNAL"
PROFILES MANY PARENTS THINK
THEY CAN SEE THE GHOSTS,
SPECTERS AND MOVEMENT ON THE
ADVANCED BABY MONITORS.
THAT MEANS A BABY IS THERE.
SOME PARENTS DESCRIBE BLURRY
HUMANOID FIGURES AND OTHERS
SEE BRIGHT ORBS.
BRET LARSON IS JOINING US.
WHAT IS THE DEAL?
>> IT'S INTERESTING.
MORE OF US PUT CAMERAS IN THE
HOME WE CAPTURE UNUSUAL
EVENTS.
BUT SOME THINK IT'S CAPTURING
A GLIMPSE OF SOMETHING
UNUSUAL.
THIS IS A BABY MONITOR.
THE COLORS IS NOTING THE
MOVEMENT BUT THE FAMILY SAYS
THE BABY WAS SLEEPING
PEACEFULLY IN THE BASSINET AND
NOTHING WAS MOVING.
WAS SOMETHING PAIR
WAS SOMETHING PARR
WAS SOMETHING PARANORMAL
WATCHING THE BABY?
AND ANOTHER GROUP WAS ALERTED
TO MOVEMENT AND THEY CHECKED
THE VIDEO AND THEY FOUND THE
CLOSET DOOR OPEN.
NEITHER OPENED THE DOOR.
ON THE REPLAY THEY SEE THE
DOOR OPEN ITSELF.
WAS IT PAIR NORMAL?
PARANORMAL?
NO.
SOMETHING FELL AND IT WAS A
BLANKET.
A CAMERA EXPERT SAID THE
LIKELY EXPLANATION IS THE DUST
PARTICLES AND CURTAINS MOVING.
IT CAUSED IT TO GO HAYWIRE.
ONE SUGGESTED IT WAS INSTALLED
INCORRECTLY.
BUT SOME DON'T ACCEPT THAT
EXPLANATION AND THEY THINK
IT'S LIKE THE LOVED ONES WHO
DIED TO KEEP A WATCHFUL EYE ON
THE HOME AND NEWBORN.
PARANORMAL INVESTIGATOR
SUGGESTED TO INSTALL A SECOND
CAMERA TO SEE IF THEY'RE
CAPTURED ON BOTH DEVICES.
I ACTUALLY HAVE A CAMERA THAT
WATCHES OVER MY DOG.
SOMETIMES IT SWITCHES OVER AND
IT IS CAPTURING THE DUST